good afternoon everyone I'm Bruce
Ralston minister of force here in
British Columbia
I'm honored to be here today on the
traditional territory of the musqueam
Squamish and slave with tooth peoples
I'm joined today by Bowen ma this is the
Minister of Emergency Management and
climate Readiness today we are providing
an update on the Wildfire situation
across our province
the Wildfire season is well underway
here in British Columbia there are
currently 86 fires burning across
British Columbia 13 of which have been
detected in just the last 24 hours
since April 1st 2023
433 wildfires have burned a total of 762
thousand hectares the 20-year average
for this time of year is 306 wildfires
and 18
000 hectares so the 20-year averages
down here and this season is way up
there the vast majority of these hectors
have burned within the Northeast region
of the province will we continue to
respond to our largest incidents as we
see more climate events and forest fires
I want to start by acknowledging all the
people who are being impacted it's
extremely difficult living day to day
with smoke or near a fire or being on an
evacuation alert or order
on behalf of all British Columbians let
me say thank you to the firefighters
First Responders Emergency Management
teams Highway Crews and communities who
are working to keep people safe
the BC Wildfire service is working
around the clock to suppress fires
reduce impacts on communities
and share up-to-date information with
you the public
as we look forward at the days ahead
parts of British Columbia will
experience rain and cooler temperatures
while this incoming weather will help
short-term firefighting efforts in some
areas people need to continue to take
precautions and be prepared
given the longer impacts longer-term
impacts of drought in British Columbia
it will not take long for any of these
Force to re that receive rain to dry out
once again
though this incoming weather is a
welcome reprieve some regions will not
receive any rain including the northeast
corner of the province there are more
than 13 100 Personnel directly engaged
in Wildfire response efforts across the
province today
let me express my appreciation to the BC
Wildfire service and other Personnel
dedicated to responding to the threats
posed by wildfires
ahead of this year we made critical
Investments the largest in the history
of our Province to strengthen Wildfire
preparedness and response
most importantly we moved the BC
Wildfire service to year-round
operations to boost fire preparedness
and planning this year BC Wildfire
service hired over a hundred permit news
permanent staff and brought on 330 new
recruits for fighting fires we've
invested in new structure protection
units drones Camp infrastructure and
Mass Water Delivery Systems to help to
assist with putting out fires and we
doubled the annual funding for Wildfire
prevention programs
even with scaled up Investments and
programs you have had a difficult fire
season to date and may well have a
difficult summer
in British Columbia wildfire and
emergency spending is statutory that
means we can spend what we need to spend
to fight fires and keep people safe
given recent history and knowing that
climate change will result in more
impactful fires we will also keep
working to increase prevention and
preparedness efforts here in British
Columbia
we can all do our part to help
firefighting efforts I encourage
everyone to fire smart their home and
property this can be as simple as
cleaning your gutter mowing your lawn or
making sure anything combustible is
stored at least 10 meters away from your
house there are many great tips in the
firesmart homeowners guide available
through the firesmart BC website
please continue to monitor government
directives prohibitions in your region
British Columbia is Big vast and
ecologically very diverse decisions
regarding prohibitions will be made
based on current and anticipated
conditions in your region currently open
burning including campfires is
prohibited across much of the province
you can find more information about
prohibitions on the BC Wildfire website
or mobile app the website and the mobile
app are also excellent sources for
up-to-date information on the locations
and details of all active wildfires in
British Columbia
you can also report a Wildfire by using
the app or by calling
555 that's five four times in a row from
a cell phone let me now pass it over to
minister Mall thank you
thank you Minister Ralston and good
afternoon everyone I too am honored to
be here on the traditional territories
at the musqueam Squamish and celebrity
peoples
as you've heard we have seen an early
start to the Wildfire season and it is
already impacting communities right
across the province
over two thousand seven pardon me let me
just say that again over 2
750 people are under an evacuation order
in the Peace River Regional District the
District of Tumblr Ridge and the
northern Rockies Regional municipality
I know that this is an incredibly
challenging time I want to assure you
that Wildfire service and Emergency
Management Personnel are working hard to
keep you and your community safe
emergency support services are available
to those who have been evacuated and
require assistance including
accommodation food transportation and
incidentals I want to thank all of the
volunteers on the ground who are appears
on the ground who are administering
these emergency Support Services
please know you must be registered with
the emergency Support Services Program
to receive emergency Support Services I
also want to remind everyone across the
province that it is now possible for you
to pre-register with emergency support
services online using the evacuee
registration and assistance tool this
can be found at
ess.gov.bc.ca you do not have to be at
risk of an imminent evacuation in order
to pre-register any British Columbian
can pre-register for emergency Support
Services now
pre-registration means that if you are
evacuated from your home you will be
processed at a Reception Center more
quickly and able to access emergency
Support Services right away again
individuals and families can now
pre-register at ess.gov.vc.ca
I recognize this is also a difficult
time for people and businesses impacted
by Highway 4 the highway foreclosure due
to the Cameron Lake Bluffs wildfire
the daily scheduled convoys carrying
essential Goods continues trucks are
getting through and we're focused on
reopening the highway as soon as it is
safe to do so
We are continuing to work closely with
impacted local communities the tourism
industry and other Industries
the challenges we are facing here in BC
due to wildfires are sadly not unique to
our Province and we continue to
coordinate with the federal government
as well
as we move further into the Wildfire
season I urge people to stay informed
and be prepared while our government is
making sure that supports and resources
are in place for the upcoming Wildfire
season it is equally important that
people start putting together a plan
like I said last week now is the time to
prepare yourselves your family your home
and your community for any potential
fires follow all fire bans and avoid
activity that may result in a wildfire
whether you live near an active Wildfire
or not I encourage every British
Columbian to take 20 minutes out of
their day to put together an emergency
plan including packing a grab and go kit
so that you are prepared to leave
immediately if you are required to
evacuate
The Province First Nations and local
authorities will continue to be there to
assist families and individuals who need
accommodation and assistance
if you are evacuated and find it more
suitable to stay with family and friends
you are still eligible to receive
emergency Support Services if you
require assistance to help with costs
relating to bulleting food and
incidentals make sure that you register
with emergency Support Services to
receive these supports
my Ministry continues to work closely
with First Nations local authorities and
other partners to identify communities
and venues that can support evacuees in
the event of a large-scale evacuation
during emergencies The Province
amplifies all evacuation alerts and
orders issued by communities on
emergency info BC dot CA and on the
emergency info BC Twitter account
The Province may also issue broadcast
intrusive alerts for evacuations on
behalf of communities
it is incredibly important that British
Columbians are aware of these sources of
information before an emergency takes
place
lastly as a reminder if you are placed
under an evacuation order you must
evacuate immediately your local
Authority or First Nation will provide
information on evacuation routes and
reception centers for you to go to
I know that leaving the place that you
love and call home during an emergency
is difficult but by staying behind you
are putting yourselves and others in
danger
I want to reiterate The Importance of
Being prepared by taking steps to be
prepared and knowing where to find
emergency information by doing so we can
all gain a sense of control sense of
safety and peace of mind
preparedbc.ca has excellent resources
available in multiple languages to get
you started
so let's continue to look forward to all
of the joy that summer brings while
recognizing the potentially challenging
situations ahead
stay calm be alert and be prepared with
that I'll pass the microphone back to
minister Ralston
great thanks very much we're now going
to call upon the three
experts from the various Ministries I
think Chris was first
[Music]
okay thank you very much everyone if
media have questions please press star
one to end
Minister we do also have
questions our first question for today
we'll go to Richard zusman Global News
okay
we're going to move on to Wolf depner
black press Morse code
hello hi is that wolf
please go ahead
yeah thank you
um thank you for taking my question
um to the issue of resources
with the federal government about about
resources here the federal government
has talked uh to
um to other jurisdictions around the
world to get to get more firefighters to
come to Canada
um can you update the public on
um were those efforts stand
um I know the European Union is sending
over sending over firefighters to Quebec
uh what if any additional resources can
BC expect to receive in the coming in
the coming days from weeks
thank you very much that's uh an
excellent question and we will not run
out of personnel there are a number of
Arrangements both at the national level
as you mentioned and internationally to
provide Mutual assistance so when
British Columbia needs support we we
know we can count on it I'll turn that
over to uh uh I think it's Ian who can
give further detail on that
and we're all part of the Canadian
interagency forest fire uh community and
we use that agency called City uh to put
in requests for resource support from
generally some other jurisdictions in
Canada obviously this year and the
spring has been unique in that there
aren't very many resources available in
Canada as the hazard and the Fire season
has started early as we are all well
aware with what's going on and has gone
on in Alberta and obviously Quebec and
Ontario have started to see fires as
well as Saskatchewan and the territories
so so the the request to recency has now
gone International uh we have had
supports come into Canada from Australia
from Mexico the European Union as a
reference and we have put holds in with
60 that we will be looking for are
potentially looking for support over the
course of the next three weeks at this
time in DC we have enough resource
capacity to manage the fires that are on
the landscape as well as be prepared for
potential new missions from lightning
caused fires uh and but we have put in
requests to support our agency and
support this province really for the
next three four weeks so that we have
the ability to rest our own staff who
have been going since the middle of
April uh and we are going to see some of
that start to come into DC uh as early
as this weekend uh we may see some staff
come in from the United States which
will be great to be able to give some of
our staff some rest and recovery and
have them available for July we've also
been in conversations about potentially
looking at firefighting resources from
other agencies including agencies
uh it's really I almost call it an
international partnership where we are
we are really trying to work
collectively across the globe to support
and surge to agencies that need it at
this time DC is not at the Forefront of
one of those agencies but we are we are
putting in requests in advance of when
we believe we will need the resources so
that we can effectively plan for the
summer ahead
wolf
hey
um at at this stage uh What uh how much
additional money uh does the province
sort of estimate uh will be needed uh to
um to help deal with this um of this
fire situation
um obviously the the situation is
evolving
um no one no one has a crystal ball
looking into into what the situation is
going to be in in July and August but
what um what what sort of ballpark
figure are we talking about here in
terms of additional resources needed
um to potentially respond uh to as as
the minister said they're very
challenging Fire season
before I turn it over to Cliff let me
just say that the as I said in my
comments uh spending on wildfires is
statutory there there's no need to go
back to uh any of the treasury board
processes the money is available when
it's needed and so that is is not a
concern in terms of a specific estimate
of how much uh we're likely to spend uh
this season I think that's uh that would
be hard to estimate but I'll I'll let
Cliff make any additional comments that
he might want to
thank you Minister Ralston and I agree
with with exactly what you said it's
very difficult to forecast what the Fire
season will look like in July and August
obviously when we did our briefing last
week we talked about the potential of a
very challenging Fire season I'd say
that the one thing we could do is look
past look in the past
2017-2018 2021 and look at the numbers
that came out of years like that and I
don't have them in front of me but as a
ballpark estimate it was roughly 500
million dollars uh in direct response
recovery cost associated with those fire
Seasons uh and and slightly up from
there depending on which of those three
years so certainly we can get those
numbers uh to the media after this call
but you know that's a that's a I guess a
reference point but again uh until we
know the conditions of July August
September how long our fire season will
go it's very difficult to forecast those
numbers we do make efforts to do so but
it is an inherently you know it's very
inherently quite quite expensive when we
start to bring in resources from other
agencies when we have as much rotary
Wing aircraft and air tanker recruit
aircraft that we already have in this
province I believe we're up to just
under 80 helicopters that are on
contract for BC Wildfire service right
now we have a fleet of just under 30 uh
swing air tanker aircraft and bird dog
aircraft so you know we have a lot of
capacity on the ground right now and in
the air right now and so looking back at
2021 17 and 18 would give us a good
starting point about the potential cost
of a season if it if it continues on the
trajectory that we've been on so far
this spring
our next question comes from Richard
zussman Global News Richard please go
ahead
to the ministers I know we keep hearing
reference to 17 18 and 21 the years of
the province declared state of
emergencies is the preparation here that
DC is preparing itself to call a state
of emergency and at what point does that
get determined uh considering that we
you know can't predict what the next
what's going to unfold over the next few
weeks and months and that question over
to my colleague Minister mom
thank you very much for that question
so to be clear uh the Wildfire act
includes quite substantial tools to
enable Province to respond to Wildfire
situations including the deployment of
resources the spending of money and so
forth however we are constantly
evaluating the situation and trying
trying to project the trends that we're
seeing on the ground if there are
circumstances where we may need to
access emergency provisions of the
emergency program act than a provincial
state of emergency could be called some
of those emergency Provisions might
include orders to restrict movement in
certain areas of the province it could
involve the um the establishment or the
commandeering of Supply chains it could
also include price fixing of Commodities
these are extraordinary powers that we
don't throw around lightly the decision
to declare a provincial state of
emergency is a very serious one it is
something that we're constantly
monitoring and taking a look at as as
things roll out throughout the season
hey Richard do you have a follow-up
when we last got one of these briefings
we looked at three scenarios and one of
them was predicated on how things would
unfold over what is now the last few
weeks did we get enough rain in this
province to be helpful over the last
week or two are we still significantly
worried like what was the LA what
unfolded over the last week or two that
helped dictate or potentially predict
what we're going to see over the next
few weeks and months
we were very grateful for the rain that
we saw over the last several days but
from what I understand it uh it was not
enough to alleviate our concerns I mean
perhaps I'll pass it on to Cliff Chapman
of the BC Wildfire service to elaborate
further
thank you Minister Milan thank you for
the question uh so yes we got we have
rain that has fallen in particular in
the southern half of the province
including Southern Vancouver Island and
the South Coast which has been really
welcome for our organization and I think
the province at large but the challenge
as you'll recall on the briefing we did
last week is is that we need sustained
rainfall uh really through the month of
June and ideally as we start to Trend
into July and August as well we have not
seen sustained rainfall in this province
since really since we went snow free uh
and and we stopped seeing snow we've
seen uh dribs and drops and we certainly
have seen some localized downpours
with the conditions with the overwinter
drought coming out of the winter with
drought uh breaking temperature records
in late April early May doing it again
in June uh we are we are the fire
numbers are we're in a tricky spot and
and I guess to be really uh I guess not
too technical is we we need sustained
rainfall over the course of a period of
a week seven to ten days and and that's
just not in the forecast
uh right now we're going to see rain
continue we're going to see a little bit
more rain today unfortunately rain is
also coming with thunderstorms uh and
and at this time with the smoke that's
kind of blown into the south over the
last 24 hours and continue to kind of
sit over us for the next couple of days
it's very challenging to detect fires
when you have smoke and cloud cover in
the interior and up the spine of the
province so we we have seen enough to
give us I would say a good opportunity
to apply suppression tactics on our
fires that are south of Fort St John to
continue to mobilize to put guards
around those fires and use the tools and
the technologies that we use to suppress
fires so from that standpoint rain is
always going to be welcome from a
long-term Hazard standpoint we are still
in conditions where it's not going to
take very much warming to turn us back
into being very prone to ignition and
very prone to fire spread so uh I guess
to put it really in summary we have four
to seven days here I think where we're
gonna see a mix of sun and clouds we're
going to see the potential of rainfall
each day uh but it's going to be
scattered and it's not going to be that
heavy downpour of 100 mils that we
sometimes see on the coast uh where
we'll be fortunate to see 10 to 20 Mills
in any given weather station over the
course of the next 10 days ideally we'll
see more but that's what we're
forecasting is roughly 5 to 15 10 to 20
mils somewhere in that uh somewhere in
that spectrum and that will help but it
won't be enough to knock down the hazard
as we enter into July and August which
typically set up as our warmer drier
hotter months where we see Ridges of
high pressure sit over the province for
sometimes weeks at a time and that's
really what we're paying attention to
now as we forward
when is that next Ridge going to come in
when is it going to stand up and start
to see our temperatures get back into
the 30s low 30s mid 30s and being able
to assess what the fire hazard is
our next question comes from James
Scribner Globe and Mail Jane please go
ahead
hey thank you I'm wondering about the
situation in Port Alberni and the the
number of natural disasters we've seen
in recent years that has impacted access
to to communities like portal burning
because we just had a more remote is the
problems giving any serious thought to
bettering emergency transportation
groups in and out of communities in more
remote areas
so first off I do want to thank the
minister of transportation and
infrastructure and the team over at Port
Alberni for how quickly they work
together to establish the detour route
that they did when the highway was shut
down they put in place a detour route
through using Forest Service Roads
extremely quickly and the convoy system
that they have put in place is allowing
trucks carrying critical supplies and
fuel in and into and out of communities
as required in the days ahead the
Ministry of Transportation will be
looking to open Highway 4 using a single
Lane alternating traffic system I'll
I'll later pass it on to Janelle state
to speak to that further but I'll also
say that we've been working very closely
with Port Alberni on other
Transportation routes as well including
options to barge fuel in for instance
when we work with communities that are
potentially stranded or cut off from
other areas as a result of a natural
disaster as a result of a wildfire we
work very very closely with them to
establish alternate Supply chains and we
use every option available to us it
could involve establishing detour routes
using for Service Roads as we
it involve using waterways and Airways
as well we leave no stone unturned in a
more proactive sense there is funding
available through the community
emergency preparedness fund administered
through ubcm provided by The Province
there's there's funding to allow
communities to actually do some of that
proactive evacuation route planning and
that proactive route planning that might
be needed during an emergency and with
that I'll pass it on to Janelle for any
further updates you may have on Highway
4.
thank you minister so as as the minister
said we are working closely with BC
Wildfire services on re-establishing the
connection directly along Highway 4. in
the interim our detour road is working
very effectively in fact this morning we
saw a convoy of eight fuel trucks go
through between Lake and portal Bernie
so demonstrating the effectiveness of
our piloted convoys and the
effectiveness of the alternate route
as a province we continue to invest in
Highway 4 to ensure that it remains safe
and reliable and that will continue
outside of this event just to ensure
that that linkage is in place right now
we do have vehicles on the ground from
our maintenance contractor we've given
the okay from BC Wildfire services to
start some cleanup work below the fire
slope which is setting us on the
trajectory to be able to reopen the
Highway 4 to single Lane alternating
traffic by next weekend
do you have a follow-up Gene
yeah thank you um you mentioned that
we're expecting some help to arrive from
the states as soon as this weekend how
many firefighters can can we expect to
be arriving
thanks I'll just turn that uh more
technical question over to Cliff Chapman
thank you uh so for this weekend what
we've requested is uh an incident
management team to support us from the
United States and Incident Management
teams are highly trained highly
certified personnel with with usually
years of experience to come in and take
command of a large-scale fire uh that is
that is challenging you know our efforts
and our resourcing and so the assistant
management team will come we will put
them onto one of our priority fires and
and it will give us the ability to rest
our own instant managed one of our own
Incident Management teams we have six of
them in the DC uh and so this is a an
opportunity for us to rest one of our
Incident Management teams which again
our Incident Management teams are all
going on there their second or third
tour of Duty uh already this year which
is abnormal relative to many years in
the past 20 years where where generally
we may not start to see our Incident
Management teams deploy until July and
August so we are we're bringing the
American team up there'll be roughly 20
of them that come up this is not ground
firefighters this is actually an
incident command team to come and take
over an incident so that's what's coming
this weekend and and we put requests in
uh for the next two weeks uh that we can
cancel at any time for additional
firefighting capacity uh for ground
resources looking at uh potentially
requests for 100 firefighters but again
that's weather dependent and resource
dependent and as I said earlier we have
enough resources right now so we we
waive those requests each day to decide
whether we need to pull it or add to it
and our last question for today comes
from David Ball of the CBC David please
go ahead
oh hi a question for Minister ma please
uh it's about long-term preparation for
wildfires you mentioned about cutoffs or
isolated communities by disasters in
general as we see more of these kind of
climate related or other natural
disasters kind of compounding what's the
plan for making all communities less
likely to be isolated is there a kind of
criteria for making sure there's not a
single Road for instance into many
places or because we're also seeing the
Alaska Highway having these issues now
we saw it with the Highway 8 and
landslides uh several years ago thank
you
I'm sorry I didn't quite catch that that
question but I think it was uh probably
a more generic question about the
overall approach to Preparing
communities for emergencies in the
future
um the creation the ministry of
Emergency Management and climate
Readiness came as a demonstrative of
government's recognition that the
climate crisis is upon us and with the
impacts of the climate crisis we're
seeing more and more extreme weather
events occur more frequently
um to a greater extent so the scope
scale frequency of these natural
disasters and these extreme
weather-related emergencies is happening
is increasing through time and so the
transition of Emergency Management BC to
Emergency Management and climate
Readiness was largely to intended to
acknowledge that we can't just be good
at responding and recovering from
disasters we also have to be better at
preparing 4 and mitigating the impacts
of those disasters before they happen
under the UN Sendai framework for
disaster risk reduction the most
important first principle that we need
to take on is to understand the hazard
and to understand what climate change
actually means on the ground for
communities in Wildfire prone areas in
flood risk areas in Landslide prone
areas all across the province and so
over the next year and a half my
Ministry working with the ministry of
environment and climate change strategy
we are undertaking a disaster and
climate disaster risk and climate oh
geez a disaster and climate risk
resiliency analysis it is a long acronym
we're trying to get a um a acronym that
is more
less of a mouthful
but the
sorry I'm getting distracted because I
someone's flashing a note at me so under
that work we will be making an
assessment of how climate will impact
the
um will impact natural disasters
throughout the province so it's
incredibly important work it's very
technical work and that will hopefully
inform the uh the types of Investments
that the province is able to make into
the future and with that very roundably
answer I'll also pass it on to Ian
Cummings to see if he has any other
additions to add hopefully he heard your
question better than I did Ian
yes thanks Minister uh in addition to
the Future State uh planning and review
that the minister just mentioned
currently uh emcr uh has what we call an
advanced planning unit uh that is
working with the variety of partner
Ministries
uh and most importantly the BC Wildfire
service in looking at uh where the fires
are now uh on the landscape and uh using
their Predictive Services Branch taking
a look at uh in some ways a very
scientific crystal ball about where the
fire may move to so we can work with uh
indigenous communities and local
governments that may be isolated by uh
Wildfire to make them better prepared in
a situation uh in which to respond to
that in terms yourself uh being able to
have more than one Road in and one road
out for each community in British
Columbia uh well I would suggest that
certainly a lofty goal to achieve those
that have some reference of the
topography uh the province that can
prove difficult but we're confident
through a hard dance planning efforts
that we can help our partners be in a
better position to respond if required
thank you
thank you sorry I was not heard I
specifically about isolated communities
from all kinds of disasters not just
fires
isolation we've seen multiple times
what we've seen in the case of Port
Alberni is that when we work together we
are able to establish alternate routes
quite quickly and we leave no stone
unturned in terms of how
supplies and fuel to communities how we
help communities access the essential
services that they require it can
involve establishing detour routes using
Forest Service Roads it can involve
taking into account
waterways whether barging is an option
boating is an option we also use
aircraft as well so when a community is
isolated we will work with them we will
make sure that uh that those essential
services and supplies get there but in
terms of advanced planning the community
emergency preparedness fund does provide
funding to communities to evaluate their
evacuation routes and evacu and evaluate
those kinds of alternative routes that
may be required to imagine that we can
anticipate the kinds of impacts that are
going to happen in every Community
across the province is uh well I
probably not quite uh well it's it's
very difficult to anticipate what will
happen in this Wildfire season but
that's why we have to be flexible we
have to be fast we have to be agile when
dealing with these situations
thank you very much everyone that
concludes today's event